hey guys in this video we're going to be
covering MongoDB in depth and most of
the content from this video is part of a
10 project course in MongoDB that I did
so if you enjoy it I would suggest
checking that course out too and I'll
leave a link in the description so we're
not going to be building a web
application or anything like that using
other technologies I really want to just
focus on MongoDB and basically the
syntax how to create collections insert
documents update and delete documents
create users and some of the other
fundamentals of MongoDB alright so
is what's called a no SQL database and
there's different types of no SQL
databases so to be more specific it's a
called a document database
alright data or records are stored as
documents and they use JSON like syntax
so if you don't know what jason is it's
JavaScript object notation and I'll get
into the syntax in a minute so notice ql
databases are much different than
relational databases like say mysql or
Postgres with a relational database you
really have to map out everything you
need to figure out the exact schema
including what tables you use what
fields you'll use and even the types of
fields ok whether it's going to be a
string or an integer all that stuff so
with no SQL there's there's not really
any of that I mean you should plan out
the structure of your database and your
collections but you don't have to do any
predefined structuring before you build
your application alright one of the huge
advantages to MongoDB and no SQL
databases in general is scaling ok
they're really easy to scale compared to
SQL or relational databases they're also
much faster in most types of operations
there are some things that would it
would benefit by using relational
databases but when you're dealing with
just a crapload of data then no SQL is
usually the way to go all right as long
as there's not really a ton of
interconnected relationships
all right so enough talking about
methodology let's jump in and get
started so I'm using Windows in the
course I mentioned we do use Linux
Ubuntu quite a bit but for this
particular video we're using Windows so
we're going to go to MongoDB comm and
you want to click the download button
here and that should take us to the
download page and we're going to go
ahead and choose this version here it
says Windows Server 2008 that's fine
64-bit so we're going to go ahead and
download that alright which I already
did so it's 104 megabytes so it might
take a couple minutes but I already have
it downloaded so I'm going to cancel
that and we're going to go ahead and run
that MSI file so I'm going to click Next
and just go through this looks up the
terms now I think I'm going to choose
custom because I want to change the
location ok by default it's going to go
in your Program Files folder and then
DB server 3.2 I want it much more
simple than that the path so I want to
just go right to my C Drive so in my C
Drive I'm going to create a folder
called Luongo DB and then we're going to
just open that and click OK
ok so much simpler it's just right in
the C Drive ok we'll click Next and then
install and we'll say yes okay so that's
finished we'll click finish and there's
still a couple steps we need to do we
need to open up a command line as
administrator ok and I have that nice
and big so you can see it and also we're
going to go to that folder and C Drive
MongoDB and we're going to create a
couple folders here I'm going to create
one called data and we're going to
create one called log all right and then
inside data we're going to have another
one called DB ok and that's where all
the data will be stored on the
filesystem and now let's go to our
command line here and we're going to
navigate to
the MongoDB folder and then into into
the bin folder all right now in here we
need to run D and we're going to
add a bunch of flags here so the first
one is going to be Directory / dB all
right and then we want to specify DB
path which is going to be the path to
the the folder we just created so C
Drive slash DB slash data slash
and if you didn't install in your C
Drive MongoDB just put whatever location
you used all right and that's why I
wanted to change that data that long
location path alright so after that
we're going to say - - log path and
that's going to be C Drive slash MongoDB
slash log and then I'm going to say
slash dot log ok so that's going
to be the file that all the MongoDB logs
right - and then we just want to specify
- - log append and - - rest and then - -
install ok and that's going to allow us
to run it as a service so let's go ahead
and run that and now we should be able
to run the service with net start
MongoDB okay and now it says it's
starting and it started successfully ok
so we now have MongoDB installed and
it's also running in the background as a
service now we're going to be working in
the shell and we can run that by
simply typing from within the bin
directory
alright so we're now in the shell I'm
just going to do think CLS and that
clears everything out now to show us a
list of databases we can do show DBS and
it shows us that there's one default
database they are called local which
we're not going to touch we want to
create a new database
so to do that we're going to say use and
then whatever we want to call it will
say my customers and you can see that
not only did it create it but it also
switched us to that database and if you
ever want to check what current database
you're in you can just do DB and it'll
tell you I just want to quickly go over
the syntax for a document so I'm going
to open up notepad and a lot of the
queries that I do I'm going to put a
notepad first and then just copy them
and paste them in just for readability
alright now basically when we're working
with a document it's just like a JSON
object or a JavaScript object we have
set of curly braces and then we have a
field with a value okay and then a comma
and you can just keep adding fields so
let's say if we have a customer we may
want them to have a first name
okay strings will have quotes around
them and let's say last name all right
so these are just very simple string
fields alright of string values if you
want we can also have an array as a
value so let's say maybe there's
memberships and we want an array with
all the different memberships that this
user is in that this customer is in so
maybe mem one and M two and so on okay
so we can have arrays we can also have
objects so let's say address and that's
represented with curly braces and you
might have a street and a city and so on
okay you can also have arrays of objects
so maybe we'll have one called phones
and actually is that that's not really a
good example maybe contacts so if we
have an array
and you may have let's say named Brad
whoops and then maybe a relationship
friend and so on
all right you could do a comma here and
then add another one so you have
different types of value now before we
go and we start inserting data I want to
just create a simple user for this
database so if we go to I'm just going
to search for it will say MongoDB create
user ok so DB dot create user will
create a user for that database and this
format here so we're going to say over
here DB dot create user and we'll pass
in some curly braces and let's specify
what is it user user and we'll just say
Brad and then password PWD and roles ok
roles I believe is an array okay can be
an array of objects but I think we can
make it more simple yeah I just want
this right here read/write so that we
can read and write to the database and
also as an admin so I'm just going to
grab that and it'll paste that in and
then let's copy that paste that in and
run it and now you'll see it says
successfully added user ok so now that
we have a user let's start to add some
data so to do that we use insert so we
say DB dot and then whatever like the Co
we didn't create a collection did we all
right so let's back up a little bit
collections are very similar to tables
in a relational database basically
they're just they hold documents or
records so to create a collection we're
going to say DB
create collection and pass in the name
of the collection which will say
customers all right and then if we want
to see all the collections in this
database we can simply say show
collections all right now if we want to
insert a document into that collection
we say DB dot customers dot insert all
right and then that's going to take in
some curly braces and let's say first
name John last name Doh okay so if we go
ahead and run that we get an inserted
one okay so it inserted one document now
if we want to see the documents in a
collection we can say DB dot customers
dot find and you can see it gives us
that list of documents which we only
have one has a first name and last name
but it also has this underscore ID field
which is set to be an object ID all
right and this is used as a unique value
to find documents and do some other
stuff but notice that it was
automatically created okay so we don't
have to worry about creating an ID field
setting it to auto increment saying
setting it as a primary key these are
all things that you have to do in a
relational database all right so let's
go ahead and add a couple more now if we
want to add multiple documents at once
we can just make an array so put square
brackets oops
square brackets around it like that and
let's change this name change them to
Stephen Smith and then let's put a comma
here and then another user or customer
with the first name will say Joan last
name will say Johnson okay now with a
relational database we would have to
specify that the customers table would
have to have a first name and a last
name and that's it they couldn't just
on-the-fly add another field and that's
what's great about no askew ellos we can
do that so for this George own Johnson
let's say we want to add a gender and
we'll set that as females
okay so set that is female and then
let's go ahead and enter and now if we
do a find you'll see that Joan has a
gender field okay even though we didn't
specify that for John and Steven it's
fine okay you can have whatever fields
you want on whatever documents you want
all right now we only have a couple
fields so this is this looks nice and
clean but if you have a ton of fields
here it can get kind of messy so we can
add on to find we can say dot pretty
just kind of a helper function and
you'll see that it makes it nice and
neat for us all right so let's look at
updating a field all right so let's say
that for John Doe we want to add a
gender to him as well so what we would
do is DB dot customers dot update and
first parameter is going to be a match
so we want to match name or actually
let's do first name
- John okay so it's going to match
anyone that has the first name of John
now if you're building a production
application you probably don't want to
use something like first name because
other people can also have that name so
it's going to update all of them you
probably want to use either the object
ID or some other unique field but just
for simplicity we're going to use first
name so then the next parameter is going
to be what we want to replace it with
okay so we'll say first name John
lastname DOE and gender male right so
we'll go ahead and run that it says it
matched one modified one so if we look
at the find now you can see that John
Doe has a gender of male now notice when
we did the update we had to also specify
first and last name again even though it
was already there if we didn't do that
and we just said gender male it would it
would basically replace the entire thing
with just that gender male now there is
a way around that and that's by using
the set operator all right so let's say
Steven Smith we want to add a gender to
him all right so we can say update and
let's say first name equal to Steven and
then for the second parameter I'm just
going to get rid of this okay we do want
to keep the curly braces and inside
there we're going to say dollar signs
set all right and then we're going to
set that to another set of curly braces
and we'll say gender male so using set
it's going to keep whatever is there
previously and then just add this on so
if we go ahead and run that and then we
do a find you'll see that Steven Smith
still has his first name and last name
and just added the gender now we also
have an operator called Inc which can
increment numeric values for us so first
thing I want to do is just add - Steven
I'm going to add an age and let's say 45
actually we want to get rid of the
quotes 45 all right so now if we do a
find I can see that he has an age of 45
now if we want to increment that we can
say DB dot customers dot update and we
want to match first name Steven and then
here we want to put our curly braces and
then we're going to specify dollar sign
Inc go like that and then we want to age
and then the number we want to increment
so let's increment 5 okay you just aged
five years let's see what oh I didn't
put curly braces around this all right
so now if we do fine you see that Steven
is now 50 okay it added five incremented
now we also have an operator called
unset if we want to remove a field so
let's say DB
dot customers dot update and we want to
specify first name Steven and then let's
put for our next parameter we're going
to say dollar sign unset and we'll say
unset I think we can do unset age let's
try that nope
age is not defined all right so we need
to do unset and then curly braces and
then age
I think it's like that yeah okay so age
one and then let's do a find and now
Steven doesn't have age anymore now
let's see what happens if we try to
update something that isn't a match
something that isn't there
alright so let's say DB customers update
and put in some curly braces and we'll
say first name first name Mary and then
we want to update we'll say first name
Mary and last name Samson all right so
let's go ahead and run that and you'll
see that the result is zero all across
so if we do a fine now it's just it's
the same but if we want to say if this
isn't found then insert it we can add an
option called up cert so let's go back
to that query and then we're going to
set a third parameter here which is some
options and we're going to say up cert
set that to true and then we'll run that
now you can see that we get one inserted
or up sorted rather and it also includes
an object ID so now if we do our find
you can see that mary has now been added
and an object IDs been created now we
also have an operator called rename that
we can use with update so if we say DV
dot customers Tod update DV customers
update and let's say where first-name is
equal to Steven and then for the second
parameter here we're going to say
let's do curly braces and then rename
and we should be able to rename let's
say gender we'll rename that to sex
I think that's the syntax rename oh not
wait we got to put curly braces around
this okay alright so now if we do a find
now you can see that with Steve Smith
gender has changed to sex alright so
those are some of the operators we can
use with update now to remove documents
is very easy we can just say DB dot
customers dot remove and then let's
specify where first-name is equal to
Steven okay you can see we get n removed
one and now if we do a find Stephens
gone now by default that query we just
ran the remove it would delete all
customers with the first name of Stephen
but you could add a parameter here you
could set inside your options there's
one called just one and you could set
that to true alright I believe it's true
true or one but you can set that and
then it's only going to delete the first
Stephen it finds it's not going to
delete all of them alright so just kind
of a safety option alright so I want to
show you a few other things but I want
some more data to work with so I'm going
to in notepad I'm going to just paste in
a query to add some more data alright so
we basically just have an insert here
with some fields for a customer's first
name last name gender age address which
is an object memberships which is an
array and then balance okay so we have
what is it I think five four or five of
them so I'm going to copy this
and we're going to go over here and
paste that in and run it you can see
it's inserted five so if we go and we do
find you can see the different customers
that were added all right now I think up
to this point we've just done find with
no parameters so what I want to do is DB
customers dot find and we can pass in a
query here so let's say we want to find
Sharon
so we could say first name Sharon okay
and that's going to give us all Sharon's
information now let's say we wanted to
find Sharon in Troy all right so what we
could do is use the we could use the or
operator so let's say DB dot customers
dot find and let's pass in our curly
braces and then we're going to say
dollar sign or set that and then put
some square brackets for an array and
we'll say first name Sharon put a comma
here and I'll stay first name
Troy okay if we run that you can see
that it gives us back Troy's information
and Sharon's okay now we can do a simple
find for a different field that is going
to match multiple results so for
instance gender if we say find gender
and change that to male if we run that
it's going to give us everybody that has
the gender of male now we can also use
greater than or less than operators so
let's say we want to find everyone that
is under the age of 40 so we'll say DB
dot
customers dot find and in here we're
going to pass in age and in here we're
going to set I'm going to open up some
curly braces and we'll say dollar sign
GT and we'll set that to actually do we
want to do less than I'll do LT set that
to forty okay and that's given us back
actually let's add pretty to the end
here okay so that gives us back
everybody that is under forty you see
Troy's thirty three twenty three and
thirty five all right and obviously you
can do GT for greater than all right now
there's also LTE which is less than or
equal to and GTE which is greater than
or equal to now let's say we want to
find everyone that lives in the city of
Boston so you can see that we have for
our address which is an object which has
street city and state so what we can do
is we'll say DB dot customers dot find
and here we're going to say we're going
to use quotes here and say address dot
city and then here we'll say Boston okay
we run that and it gives us two people
that have their city as Boston okay when
we're dealing with objects like this we
have to wrap it in quotes you'll see if
I go and take these quotes off it gives
us an error and I should mention that
there are some clients and programs that
will require you to use quotes in the
key as well so just remember that if
you're having issues and some other
client just try that and see if that
helps
alright now if we want to query the
memberships okay remember memberships is
an array
then that's pretty easy all we have to
do is customers dot find and let's say
memberships and then just the name of it
so let's say mem one okay so that's
going to give us everyone that has mem
one inside their memberships array
alright now next thing I want to talk
about is sorting okay so let's do a find
we'll say actually I'm going to clear
this out and we'll do DB dot customers
dot find and then what we can do is we
can add on to this
we'll say dot sort okay and then that's
going to take in whatever field we want
to sort by so let's say we'll do last
name
so we could say flats name one okay so
if I set it to one that means that it's
going to be in ascending order so if we
look at the last name we have Doe
Jenkins Johnson Sampson Wilkins okay if
we want a descending then we could just
set it to negative one and then you can
see whoops I want to do dot pretty okay
now you can see it's going in the
opposite direction okay we have Wilkins
at the beginning all right so that's
sorting we can also count documents so
if we want to do DB customers dot find
count and run that you can see that it
gives us eight okay we can also put a
query in here if we wanted to if we say
gender male and it gives us four okay
because there's four people that are
males we can also limit so if we want to
find we'll find everybody but we're
going to set a limit
I'll set limit to four and you can see
that it gives us the first four and of
course you can combine these
so we could say limit for dot sort and
we'll sort by city last name one and
there we go another cool thing we can do
is we can iterate through stuff using
for each alright so we'll do DB dot
customers dot find and then we want to
say dot for each and then in here we
have function we want to pass it a
variable which can be anything I'm just
going to say doc and then let's say we
want to print it is a print function we
can use and we'll print the string
customer name and then we can
concatenate onto that with a plus sign
okay just like regular JavaScript and
we'll say doc dot and then whatever
field first-name and now we get we're
printing out customer name and then
whatever the first name is alright so
we're going to go ahead and stop here
now if you enjoyed this I would suggest
checking out the ten project MongoDB
course there are a couple projects like
this where we're just dealing with the
database in the shell but there's also
projects where we're building web
applications implementing different
technologies like angular and nodejs so
I would suggest that and thanks for
watching and I'll see you next time